this is a Galton board
maybe you've seen one before it's a
popular demonstration of how even when a
single event is chaotic and random with
an effectively unknowable outcome it's
still possible to make precise
statements about a large number of
events namely how the relative
proportions for many different outcomes
are distributed
more specifically the Galton board
illustrates one of the most prominent
distributions in all of probability
known as the normal distribution more
colloquially known as a bell curve and
also called a gaussian distribution
there's a very specific function to
describe this distribution it's very
pretty we'll get into it later but right
now I just want to emphasize how the
normal distribution is as the name
suggests very common it shows up in a
lot of seemingly unrelated contexts
if you were to take a large number of
people who sit in a similar demographic
and plot their heights those Heights
tend to follow a normal distribution
if you look at a large swath of very big
natural numbers and you ask how many
distinct prime factors does each one of
those numbers have the answers will very
closely track with a certain normal
distribution now our topic for today is
one of the crown jewels in all of
probability Theory it's one of the key
facts that explains why this
distribution is as common as it is known
as the central limit theorem this lesson
is meant to go back to the basics giving
you the fundamentals on what the central
limit theorem is saying what normal
distributions are and I want to assume
minimal background we're going to go
decently deep into it but after this I'd
still like to go deeper and explain why
the theorem is true why the function
underlying the normal distribution as
the very specific form that it does why
that formula has a pie in it and most
fun why those last two facts are
actually more related than a lot of
traditional explanations would suggest
that second lesson is also meant to be
the follow-on to the convolutions video
that I promised so there's a lot of
interrelated topics here but right now
back to the fundamentals I'd like to
kick things off with a overly simplified
model of the Galton board
in this model we will assume that each
ball falls directly onto a certain
Central Peg and then it has a 50 50
probability of bouncing to the left or
to the right and we'll think of each of
those outcomes as either adding one or
subtracting one from its position once
one of those is chosen we make the
highly unrealistic assumption that it
happens to land dead on in the middle of
the peg adjacent below it where again
it'll be faced with the same 50 50
choice of bouncing to the left or to the
right for the one I'm showing on screen
there are five different rows of pegs so
our little hopping ball makes five
different random choices between plus
one and -1 and we can think of its final
position as basically being the sum of
all of those different numbers which in
this case happens to be one and we might
label all of the different buckets with
the sum that they represent as we repeat
this we're looking at different possible
sums for those five random numbers
and for those of you who are inclined to
complain that this is a highly
unrealistic model for the true gothin
board let me emphasize the goal right
now is not to accurately model physics
the goal is to give a simple example to
illustrate the central limit theorem and
for that idealized though this might be
it actually gives us a really good
example if we let many different balls
fall making yet another unrealistic
assumption that they don't influence
each other as if they're all ghosts then
the number of balls that fall into each
different bucket gives us some loose
sense for How likely each one of those
buckets is in this example the numbers
are simple enough that it's not too hard
to explicitly calculate what the
probability is for falling into each
bucket if you do want to think that
through you'll find it very reminiscent
of Pascal's triangle but the neat thing
about our theorem is how far it goes
beyond the simple examples so to start
off at least rather than making explicit
calculations let's just simulate things
by running a large number of samples and
letting the total number of results in
each different outcome give us some
sense for what that distribution looks
like as I said the one on screen has
five rows so each sum that we're
considering includes only five numbers
the basic idea of the central limit
theorem is that if you increase the size
of that sum for example here that would
mean increasing the number of rows of
pegs for each ball to bounce off then
the distribution that describes where
that sum is going to fall looks more and
more like a bell curve
here it's actually worth taking a moment
to write down that general idea
the setup is that we have a random
variable and that's basically shorthand
for a random process where each outcome
of that process is associated with some
number we'll call that random number X
for example each bounce off the peg is a
random process modeled with two outcomes
those outcomes are associated with the
numbers negative one and positive one
another example of a random variable
would be rolling a die where you have
six different outcomes each one
associated with a number what we're
doing is taking multiple different
samples of that variable and adding them
all together on our gothin board that
looks like letting the ball bounce off
multiple different pegs on its way down
to the bottom and in the case of a die
you might imagine rolling many different
Dice and adding up the results the claim
of the central limit theorem is that as
you let the size of that sum get bigger
and bigger then the distribution of that
sum How likely it is to fall into
different possible values we'll look
more and more like a bell curve
that's it that is the general idea over
the course of this lesson our job is to
make that statement more quantitative
we're going to put some numbers to it
put some formulas to it show how you can
use it to make predictions
for example here's the kind of question
I want you to be able to answer by the
end of this video
suppose you roll the die 100 times and
you added together the results
could you find a range of values such
that you're 95 sure that the sum will
fall within that range or maybe I should
say find the smallest possible range of
values such that this is true
the neat thing is you'll be able to
answer this question whether it's a fair
die or if it's a weighted die
now let me say at the top that this
theorem has three different assumptions
that go into it three things that have
to be true before the theorem follows
and I'm actually not going to tell you
what they are until the very end of the
video instead I want you to keep your
eye out and see if you can notice and
maybe predict what those three
assumptions are going to be
as a next step to better illustrate just
how General this theorem is I want to
run a couple more simulations for you
focused on the dice example
foreign
usually if you think of rolling a die
you think of the six outcomes as being
equally probable but the theorem
actually doesn't care about that we
could start with a weighted die
something with a non-trivial
distribution across the outcomes and the
core idea still holds for the simulation
what I'll do is take some distribution
like this one that is skewed towards
lower values I'm going to take 10
distinct samples from that distribution
and then I'll record the sum of that
sample on the plot on the bottom
then I'm going to do this many many
different times always with the sum of
size 10 but keep track of where those
sums ended up to give us a sense of the
distribution
and in fact let me rescale the y
direction to give us room to run an even
larger number of samples and I'll let it
go all the way up to a couple thousand
and as it does you'll notice that the
shape that starts to emerge looks like a
bell curve maybe if you squint your eyes
you can see it skews a tiny bit to the
left but it's neat that something so
symmetric emerged from a starting point
that was so asymmetric to better
illustrate what the central limit
theorem is all about let me run four of
these simulations in parallel where on
the upper left I'm doing it where we're
only adding two dice at a time on the
upper right we're doing it where we're
adding five dice at a time the lower
left is the one that we just saw adding
10 dice at a time
and then we'll do another one with a
bigger sum 15 at a time
notice how on the upper left when we're
just adding two dice the resulting
distribution doesn't really look like a
bell curve it looks a lot more
reminiscent of the one we started with
skewed towards the left
but as we allow for more and more dice
in each sum the resulting shape that
comes up in these distributions looks
more and more symmetric it has the lump
in the middle and fade towards the tail
shape of a bell curve
let me emphasize again you can start
with any different distribution here
I'll run it again but where most of the
probability is tied up in the numbers 1
and 6 with very low probability for the
mid values despite completely changing
the distribution for an individual roll
of the die it's still the case that a
bell curve shape will emerge as we
consider the different sums illustrating
things with a simulation like this is
very fun and it's kind of neat to see
order emerge from chaos but it also
feels a little imprecise like in this
case when I cut off the simulation at
3000 samples even though it kind of
looks like a bell curve the different
buckets seem pretty spiky and you might
wonder is it supposed to look that way
or is that just an artifact of the
randomness in the simulation and if it
is how many samples do we need before we
can be sure that what we're looking at
is representative of the true
distribution
instead moving forward let's get a
little more theoretical and show the
precise shape that these distributions
will take on in the long run
the easiest case to make this
calculation is if we have a uniform
distribution where each possible face of
the die has an equal probability 1 6.
for example if you then want to know how
likely different sums are for a pair of
dice it's essentially a counting game
where you count up how many distinct
pairs take on the same sum which in the
diagram I've drawn you can conveniently
Think About by going through all of the
different diagonals
since each such pair has an equal chance
of showing up 1 in 36 all you have to do
is count the sizes of these buckets that
gives us a definitive shape for the
distribution describing a sum of two
dice and if we were to play the same
game with all possible triplets the
resulting distribution would look like
this now what's more challenging but a
lot more interesting is to ask what
happens if we have a non-uniform
distribution for that single die
we actually talked all about this in the
last video you do essentially the same
thing you go through all the distinct
pairs of dice which add up to the same
value it's just that instead of counting
those pairs for each pair you multiply
the two probabilities of each particular
face coming up and then you add all
those together the computation that does
this for all possible sums has a fancy
name it's called a convolution but it's
essentially just the weighted version of
the counting game that anyone who's
played with a pair of dice already finds
familiar for our purposes in this lesson
I'll have the computer calculate all
that simply display the results for you
and invite you to observe certain
patterns but under the hood this is
what's going on
so just to be crystal clear on what's
being represented here if you imagine
sampling two different values from that
top distribution the one describing a
single die and adding them together then
the second distribution I'm drawing
represents How likely you are to see
various different sums likewise if you
imagine sampling three distinct values
from that top distribution and adding
them together the next plot represents
the probabilities for various different
sums in that case
so if I compute what the distributions
for these sums look like for larger and
larger sums well you know what I'm going
to say it looks more and more like a
bell curve
but before we get to that I want you to
make a couple more simple observations
for example these distributions seem to
be wandering to the right and also they
seem to be getting more spread out and a
little bit more flat you cannot describe
the central limit theorem quantitatively
without taking into account both of
those effects which in turn requires
describing the mean and the standard
deviation maybe you're already familiar
with those but I want to make minimal
assumptions here and it never hurts to
review so let's quickly go over both of
those
the mean of a distribution often denoted
with the Greek letter mu is a way of
capturing the center of mass for that
distribution it's calculated as the
expected value of our random variable
which is a way of saying you go through
all of the different possible outcomes
and you multiply the probability of that
outcome times the value of the variable
if higher values are more probable that
weighted sum is going to be bigger if
lower values are more probable that
weighted time is going to be smaller
a little more interesting is if you want
to measure how spread out this
distribution is because there's multiple
different ways you might do it
one of them is called the variance the
idea there is to look at the difference
between each possible value and the mean
square that difference and ask for its
expected value the idea is that whether
your value is below or above the mean
when you square that difference you get
a positive number and the larger the
difference the bigger that number
squaring it like this turns out to make
the math much much nicer than if we did
something like an absolute value but the
downside is that it's hard to think
about this as a distance in our diagram
because the units are off it's kind of
like the units here are square units
whereas a distance in our diagram would
be a kind of linear unit so another way
to measure spread is What's called the
standard deviation which is the square
root of this value that can be
interpreted much more reasonably as a
distance on our diagram and it's
commonly denoted with the Greek letter
Sigma so you know M for mean as for
standard deviation but both in Greek
looking back at our sequence of
distributions let's talk about the mean
and standard deviation if we call the
mean of the initial distribution mu
which the one Illustrated happens to be
2.24 hopefully it won't be too
surprising if I tell you that the mean
of the next one is two times mu that is
you roll a pair of dice you want to know
the expected value of the sum it's two
times the expected value for a single
die
similarly the expected value for our sum
of size 3 is 3 times mu and so on and so
forth the mean just marches steadily on
to the right which is why our
distributions seem to be drifting off in
that direction a little more challenging
but very important is to describe how
the standard deviation changes the key
fact here is that if you have two
different random variables then the
variance for the sum of those variables
is the same as just adding together the
original two variances this is one of
those facts that you can just compute
when you unpack all the definitions
there are a couple nice intuitions for
why it's true my tentative plan is to
just actually make a series about
probability and talk about things like
intuition's underlying variants and its
cousins there but right now the main
thing I want you to highlight is how
it's the variance that adds it's not the
standard deviation that adds so
critically if you were to take n
different realizations of the same
random variable and ask what the sum
looks like the variance of that sum is n
times the variance of your original
variable
meaning the standard deviation the
square root of all this is the square
root of n times the original standard
deviation
for example back in our sequence of
distributions if we label the standard
deviation of our initial one with Sigma
then the next standard deviation is
going to be the square root of 2 times
Sigma and after that it looks like the
square root of 3 times Sigma and so on
and so forth this like I said is very
important it means that even though our
distributions are getting spread out
they're not spreading out all that
quickly they only do so in proportion to
the square root of the size of the sum
as we prepare to make a more
quantitative description of the central
limit theorem the core intuition I want
you to keep in your head is that we'll
basically realign all of these
distributions so that their means line
up together and then rescale them so
that all of the standard deviations are
just going to be equal to one and when
we do that the shape that results gets
closer and closer to a certain Universal
shape described with an elegant little
function that will unpack in just a
moment and let me say one more time the
real magic here is how we could have
started with any distribution describing
a single roll of the die and if we play
the same game considering what the
distributions for the many different
sums look like and we realign them so
that the means line up and we rescale
them so that the standard deviations are
all one we still approach that same
Universal shape which is kind of
mind-boggling
and now my friends is probably as good a
time as any to finally get into the
formula for a normal distribution and
the way I'd like to do this is to
basically peel back all the layers and
build it up one piece at a time the
function e to the x or anything to the X
describes exponential growth and if you
make that exponent negative which flips
around the graph horizontally you might
think of it as describing exponential
decay to make this decay in both
directions you could do something to
make sure the exponent is always
negative and growing like taking the
negative absolute value that would give
us this kind of awkward sharp point in
the middle but if instead you make that
exponent the negative square of X you
get a smoother version of the same thing
which decays in both directions this
gives us the basic bell curve shape now
if you throw a constant in front of that
X and you scale that constant up and
down it lets you stretch and squish the
graph horizontally allowing you to
describe narrow and wider bell curves
and a quick thing I'd like to point out
here is that based on the rules of
exponentiation as we tweak around that
constant C you could also think about it
as simply changing the base of the
exponentiation and in that sense the
number e is not really all that special
for our formula we could replace it with
any other positive constant and you'll
get the same family of Curves as we
tweak that constant
make it a two same family of Curves make
it a three same family of Curves the
reason we use e is that it gives that
constant a very readable meaning or
rather if we reconfigure things a little
bit so that the exponent looks like
negative one-half times x divided by a
certain constant which we'll
subjectively call Sigma squared then
once we turn this into a probability
distribution that constant Sigma will be
the standard deviation of that
distribution and that's very nice but
before we can interpret this as a
probability distribution we need the
area under the curve to be one and the
reason for that is how the curve is
interpreted unlike discrete
distributions when it comes to something
continuous you don't ask about the
probability of a particular Point
instead you ask for the probability that
a value Falls between two different
values and what the curve is telling you
is that that probability equals the area
under the curve between those two values
there's a whole other video about this
they're called probability density
functions the main point right now is
the that the area under the entire curve
represents the probability that
something happens that some number comes
up that should be one which is why we
want the area under this to be one as it
stands with the basic bell curve shape
of e to the negative x squared the area
is not one it's actually the square root
of pi
I know right what is pi doing here what
does this have to do with circles like I
said at the start I'd love to talk all
about that in the next video but if you
can spare your excitement for our
purposes right now all it means is that
we should divide this function by the
square root of Pi and it gives us the
area we want throwing back in the
constants we had earlier the one-half
and the sigma the effect there is to
stretch out the graph by a factor of
Sigma times the square root of two so we
also need to divide out by that in order
to make sure it has an area of one and
combining those fractions the factor out
front looks like one divided by Sigma
times the square root of 2 pi
this finally is a valid probability
distribution as we tweak that value
Sigma resulting in narrower and wider
curves that constant in the front always
guarantees that the area equals one
the special case where Sigma equals 1
has a specific name we call it the
standard normal distribution which plays
an especially important role for you and
me in this lesson and all possible
normal distributions are not only
parametrized with this value Sigma but
we also subtract off another constant mu
from the variable X and this essentially
just lets you slide the graph left and
right so that you can prescribe the mean
of this distribution so in short we have
two parameters one describing the mean
one describing the standard deviation
and they're all tied together in this
big formula involving an E and A pi
now that all of that is on the table
let's look back again at the idea of
starting with some random variable and
asking what the distributions for sums
of that variable look like as we've
already gone over when you increase the
size of that sum the resulting
distribution will shift according to a
growing mean and it slowly spreads out
according to a growing standard
deviation and putting some actual
formulas to it if we know the mean of
our underlying random variable and we
call it mu and we also know its standard
deviation and we call it Sigma then the
mean for the sum on the bottom will be
mu times the size of the sum and the
standard deviation will be Sigma times
the square root of that size so now if
we want to claim that this looks more
and more like a bell curve and a bell
curve is only described by two different
parameters the mean and the standard
deviation you know what to do you could
plug those two values into the formula
and it gives you a highly explicit
albeit kind of complicated formula for a
curve that should closely fit our
distribution
but there's another way we can describe
it that's a little more elegant and
lends itself to a very fun visual that
we can build up to instead of focusing
on the sum of all of these random
variables let's modify this expression a
little bit where what we'll do is we'll
look at the mean that we expect that sum
to take and we subtract it off so that
our new expression has a mean of zero
and then we're going to look at the
standard deviation we expect of our sum
and divide out by that
which basically just rescales the units
so that the standard deviation of our
expression will equal one this might
seem like a more complicated expression
but it actually has a highly readable
meaning it's essentially saying how many
standard deviations away from the mean
is this sum
for example this bar here corresponds to
a certain value that you might find when
you roll 10 Dice and you add them all up
and its position a little above negative
one is telling you that that value is a
little bit less than one standard
deviation lower than the mean
also by the way in anticipation for the
animation I'm trying to build to here
the way I'm representing things on that
lower plot is that the area of each one
of these bars is telling us the
probability of the corresponding value
rather than the height you might think
of the y-axis as representing not
probability but a kind of probability
density the reason for this is to set
the stage so that it aligns with the way
we interpret continuous distributions
where the probability of falling between
a range of values is equal to an area
under a curve between those values in
particular the area of all the bars
together is going to be one
now with all of that in place let's have
a little fun let me start by Rolling
things back so that the Distribution on
the bottom represents a relatively small
sum like adding together only three such
random variables notice what happens as
I change the distribution we start with
as it changes the Distribution on the
bottom completely changes its shape it's
very dependent on what we started with
if we let the size of our sum get a
little bit bigger say going up to 10 and
as I change the distribution for X it
largely stays looking like a bell curve
but I can find some distributions that
get it to change shape for example the
really lopsided one where almost all the
probability is in the numbers 1 or 6
results in this kind of spiky bell curve
and if you'll recall earlier on I
actually showed this in the form of a
simulation though if you were wondering
whether that spikiness was an artifact
of the randomness or reflected the true
distribution turns out it reflects the
true distribution in this case 10 is not
a large enough sum for the central limit
theorem to kick in but if instead I let
that sum grow and I consider adding 50
different values which is actually not
that big then no matter how I change the
distribution for our underlying random
variable it has essentially no effect on
the shape of the plot on the bottom no
matter where we start all of the
information and Nuance for the
distribution of X gets washed away and
we tend towards this single Universal
shape described by a very elegant
function for the standard normal
distribution 1 over square root of 2 pi
times e to the negative x squared over
2. this this right here is what the
central limit theorem is all about
almost nothing you can do due to this
initial distribution changes the shape
we tend towards
now the more theoretically minded among
you might still be wondering what is the
actual theorem like what's the
mathematical statement that could be
proved or disproved that we're claiming
here if you want a nice formal statement
here's how it might go consider this
value where we're summing Up N different
instantiations of our random variable
but tweaked and tuned so that its mean
and standard deviation are one again
meaning you can read it as asking how
many standard deviations away from the
mean is the sum then the actual rigorous
no jokes this time statement of the
central limit theorem is that if you
consider the probability that this value
Falls between two given real numbers a
and b and you consider the limit of that
probability as the size of your sum goes
to Infinity
then that limit is equal to a certain
integral which basically describes the
area under a standard normal
distribution between those two values
again there are three underlying
assumptions that I have yet to tell you
but other than those in all of its gory
detail this right here is the central
limit theorem
foreign
all of that is a bit theoretical so it
might be helpful to bring things back
down to earth and turn back to the
concrete example that I mentioned at the
start where you imagine rolling a die
100 times and let's assume it's a fair
die for this example and you add
together the results the challenge for
you is to find a range of values such
that you're 95 sure that the sum will
fall within this range
for questions like this there's a handy
rule of thumb about normal distributions
which is that about 68 of your values
are going to fall within one standard
deviation of the mean 95 of your values
the thing we care about fall within two
standard deviations of the mean and a
whopping 99.7 percent of your values
will fall within three standard
deviations of the mean it's a rule of
thumb that's commonly memorized by
people who do a lot of probability and
stats
naturally this gives us what we need for
our example and let me go ahead and draw
out what this would look like where I'll
show the distribution for a faraday up
at the top and the distribution for a
sum of 100 such dice on the bottom which
by now as you know looks like a certain
normal distribution
step one with a problem like this is to
find the mean of your initial
distribution which in this case will
look like 1 6 times 1 plus 1 6 times 2
on and on and on and works out to be 3.5
we also need the standard deviation
which requires calculating the variance
which as you know involves adding all
the squares of the differences between
the values and the means and it works
out to be 2.92 the square root of that
comes out to be 1.71
those are the only two numbers we need
and I will invite you again to reflect
on how magical it is that those are the
only two numbers that you need to
completely understand the bottom
distribution its mean will be 100 times
mu which is 350 and its standard
deviation will be the square root of 100
times Sigma so 10 times Sigma 17.1
remembering our handy rule of thumb
we're looking for values two standard
deviations away from the mean and when
you subtract two Sigma from the mean you
end up with about 316 and when you add
two Sigma you end up with roughly 384
and there you go that gives us the
answer
okay I promise to wrap things up shortly
but while we're on this example there's
one more question that's worth your time
to ponder instead of just asking about
the sum of 100 die rolls let's say I had
you divide that number by 100 which
basically means all the numbers in our
diagram in the bottom get divided by
100. take a moment to interpret what
this all would be saying then the
expression essentially tells you the
empirical average for 100 different die
rolls and that interval we found is now
telling you what range you were
expecting to see for that empirical
average
in other words you might expect it to be
around 3.5 that's the expected value for
a die roll but what's much less obvious
and what the central limit theorem lets
you compute is how close to that
expected value you'll reasonably find
yourself
in particular it's worth your time to
take a moment mulling over what the
standard deviation for this empirical
average is and what happens to it as you
look at a bigger and bigger sample of
die rolls
[Music]
lastly but probably most importantly
let's talk about the assumptions that go
into this theorem the first one is that
all of these variables that we're adding
up are independent from each other the
outcome of one process doesn't influence
the outcome of any other process
the second is that all of these
variables are drawn from the same
distribution both of these have been
implicitly assumed with our dice example
we have been treating the outcome of
each die roll as independent from the
outcome of all the others and we're
assuming that each die follows the same
distribution
sometimes in the literature you'll see
these two assumptions lumped together
under the initials IID for independent
and identically distributed one
situation where these assumptions are
decidedly not true would be the Galton
board I mean think about it is it the
case that the way a ball bounces off of
one of the pegs is independent from how
it's going to bounce off the next Peg
absolutely not depending on the last
bounce it's coming in with a completely
different trajectory and is it the case
that the distribution of possible
outcomes off of each Peg are the same
for each Peg that it hits again almost
certainly not maybe it hits one peg
glancing to the left meaning the
outcomes are hugely skewed in that
direction and then hits the next one
glancing to the right
when I made all those simplifying
assumptions in the opening example it
wasn't just to make this easier to think
about it's also that those assumptions
were necessary for this to actually be
an example of the central limit theorem
nevertheless it seems to be true that
for the real Galton board despite
violating both of these a normal
distribution does kind of come about
part of the reason might be that there
are generalizations of the theorem
beyond the scope of this video that
relax these assumptions especially the
second one but I do want to caution you
against the fact that many times people
seem to assume that a variable is
normally distributed even when there's
no actual justification to do so
the third assumption is actually fairly
subtle it's that the variance we've been
Computing for these variables is finite
this was never an issue for the dice
example because there were only six
possible outcomes but in certain
situations where you have an infinite
set of outcomes when you go to compute
the variance the sum ends up diverging
off to Infinity
these can be perfectly valid probability
distributions and they do come up in
practice but in those situations as you
consider adding many different
instantiations of that variable and
letting that sum approach infinity even
if the first two assumptions hold it is
very much a possibility that the thing
you tend towards is not actually a
normal distribution
if you've understood everything up to
this point you now have a very strong
foundation in what the central limit
theorem is all about and next up I'd
like to explain why it is that this
particular function is the thing that we
tend towards and why it has a pie in it
what it has to do with circles
[Music]
thank you
foreign